I have been wanting to make this video
for years.
A see-through suppressor with a high speed camera
COME ON!
This is awesome!
The problem is I didn't
have access to licenses or the equipment necessary to make it.
All that changed when I met Steve.
Hey it's me Dustin, welcome back to Smarter Every Day.
I'm with Steve and Steve makes suppressors, right?
That right.
What's the name of the company?
Soteria
Suppressors
(Here to fire off suppression)
Okay this is something we've been wantin' to do
FOREVER
This is a Good old Boy Alabama deal i've contacted steve he's contacted me he likes the high-speed camera i like the concept
Of See-through Suppressors so we worked out a Little Deal Here when you Say all right so what are we gonna do
We're gonna fire our suppressors with
Using a cast Acrylic as a Casing we Can Actually See What transpires
Inside the suppressor once you know the Round leaves the barrel and
The Compressed gases behind It you know come on a barrel Create pressure wave in the ignition of The gases?
We get to see what Actually
As the bullet comes Out from the end as It Expands
So you Got this this Expansion coming Over Here towards Your microphone right right so what i i wouldn't Expect This pressure field to be
Symmetric or even Spherical it'S gonna be it's gonna be like a Lobe Correct a
reverse mushroom and You can See that if we Take The Muzzle brake off of It and you can Actually See
When the When the Round Exits the barrel Within on course you can See that reverse mushroom Cloud oh?
That's awesome The moment we've Been Waiting for
There we Go this is ptfc seal
Steve Would like to say something
I can Say full disclosure here we've never fired the 308 with a cast acrylic suppressor before
I think it's gonna break i do
so
But My guess is if It Does Fail That we're gonna get a Failure right Here near the thread on the back?
or the front and That's because of the
Stress Concentration What Kind of Thread did You use is a Sharp-toothed Thread This truncated Thread It'S a fine Thread
Hopefully It won't but if It if It does we're gonna Get some Great High speed Hints the Lexan
There we Go
I think it broke Where i thought it Would
Yeah My engineering professor Didn't lie to me
Have You ever Seen that? I've never seen that
I've never seen anybody do that before
I've never seen ANYBODY do that before!
Munford People What's Mumford People Mumford usa Mumford Alabama Mumford Us i don't understand the reference
We'd be recnecks.
But we Design and Stuff The fact that It came off had to do with Axial stress like iF once It pressurized That Tube
It's pulling the Whole
Can And Those Threads Just Couldn't Handle That Right Right
Okay so the one we're about to do is something you Actually sell That's right and you've Never Seen It like This? Never have
Cool so this is a .223 and the idea here is to?
Contain The Gasses in the back and Then Stop It from exiting with that Diamond Pattern in the front
so if you think about What the suppressor is doing there's two Stages to it the first one is the
Capture of The gases on the inside of is Expansion volume and Then There's This Restriction to flow
To keep Those Gases Inside the can so you don't let them flow out
There's This Really Cool Thing That happens when you Spend a Lot of time Designing Things
Eventually You start to see things and you Just Kind of have a Gut Feel like engineering Judgment on this next suppressor
Steve had that Gut Feel right before we Pulled the trigger he can Hear him yell out it's pretty fun
he didn't want to shoot This i
Convinced Him to do it Because It Was the prettiest one in my Mind i thought i could see more of the gases what steve?
Didn't tell me is that This Was one of the first conceptual designs Sotiria made back before They'd done much Research
He also didn't tell me that he had no Intentions of Shooting This one so he made it out of Thinner
Acrylic As a Display Piece it's got like This claw Built into it and that Claw Kind of Looks like it's going to
Grab Some of That gas and not Let It Go so I'm Pretty pumped about that You Ready
Ready to fire!
Why didn't you tell me! I did it i said full disclosure and you went on with the test anyway
I said it was my favorite
Because This ones Got claws it's my favorite design and you Knew it was gonna
How did you know it was gonna fail in all seriousness?
Well It Was a Smaller Diameter
On that .308 It Works Well on the .223 but on the .308 we Need more capacity
That's a 30
That's 35 millimeter
Suppressor It Needs to be like 41 millimeter
This Is a Developmental test so let's see what we can Learn
Instead of Using a segmented Baffle System This Type of suppressor Uses a Monocore Design so it can Be Easily Cleaned in the field
We fired Another Round Through The monocle Without containment so we could see exactly
What was happening as you can See these flat parts are flexing Out from the inside and They're pushing on the inside of the sleeve
Causing a Localized stress Concentration This is Called destructive testing and it's my favorite Part of engineering
Steve obviously Knew this was going to break if we Used a metal can and this Wouldn't
Have Shattered But What he did is he weakened one part of The system so that We Could See how strong the other
Components were won't you figure that out you can figure out
How to tweak your design and you can make a Really strong
Overall Product Without Making It Too Bulky This is Really Smart and it's something That engineers do all The time and it's one of My
favorite Things in engineering ok That Was everything i thought It Would Be It was Rad i've Got a super cool
Sponsor to introduce to you today This is not a normal ad This is a
Really Big Deal For The Sandlin Household We Have Been hoping that hellofresh Would sponsor smarter Every day for a Really long Time
I'll Let my Wife who talked about This on the podcast i'll let her Explain How our?
relationship With hellofresh Started Would You like to Explain How this came about i
Basically Bought Myself a
Subscription for Christmas so i wouldn't have to do as Much meal planning or shopping for the new year and other People have?
Asked to support Smarter Every day are these Milk refining Type Things
Yes and other meal planning companies Have sent us Meals and i did not?
Like The Setup or the Food options and so i went back to paying for hello fresh because i enjoyed it Better
We Really Wanted hello fresh
To sponsor smarter Every day for us it's all about What It Does for our Family my oldest son Enjoys Learning
How to cook and he Helps tara in the Kitchen Healthy ready to cook Meals are delivered Directly to your door with Perfectly portioned
Ingredients to avoid Food Ways tara and i Enjoy the fact that we don't
Have to Plan ahead and Go Shop for specific ingredients we can Just pull stuff Out of the fridge and the instructions are Clear
And Ready to go in the included recipe Card
Been awesome for our Family each Meals less Than Ten Bucks and Only Takes about 30 minutes
Go to hellofresh.com and use the promo code smarter to get $30 off Your first weeks
Subscription it's Really Worth It That promo code in Green Beans Is hellofresh calm and use the promo code
Smarter a Couple Things Real quick the Next couple videos i'm
Super Excited About If You've never Considered Subscribing if You think This One Earned It It might be a Good time also
Number two if you want to see Just more Raw slow-mo the second Channel smarter Every day - Gordon McGladdery did the sound Design There's
more Sounds and slo-mo over There
Go Check It out it's really Rad
Let's go Say Bye The Steve alright That's it i hope You enjoyed This episode of Smarter Every day Big thanks to Steve from Soteria
For Letting Us come out and shoot your stuff so probably That Enjoyed It a Great time so we're gonna do some design Work Here
That's right so we Learned Someday That we're gonna try other Things Based on it what do you think i believe it
awesome Man Thanks science Keeps Moving dude it'S gonna be Good
Awesome I'm Destin getting Smarter Every day have a good one
Do you have a guess?
I'm guessing you're wrong okay you know i'll bet you coke on It a coke? all right so it's good bet ya a coke